there is breaking news overnight about
syria where u.s special operations
forces carried out a counter-terrorism
rate moments ago president biden said
the troops took the leader of isis off
the battlefield rescue workers in syria
say at least 13 people died david martin
has more from the pentagon crumbling
concrete and rubble is evidence of the
deadly u.s special operations raid
carried out overnight in syria
it happened in the town of atma not far
from the turkish border
an area of northwest syria known as a
hotbed for terrorist organizations
reports from residents on the ground say
the raid lasted two hours and involved
helicopters explosives and machine gun
fire
in a statement the pentagon said the
mission was successful which should mean
the target was killed or captured there
were no u.s casualties but a defense
official said one helicopter broke down
and had to be destroyed and left behind
according to residents and activists u.s
troops used loudspeakers urging women
and children to leave the area
there was at least one explosion
it was the largest u.s raid in syria
since the 2019 operation that killed
islamic state leader abu bakr
al-baghdadi who blew himself up rather
than be captured the pentagon has not
yet identified the target of this raid
although it comes just days after the
islamic state stage a major attack on a
prison camp which holds some 3 000 of
its members
for cbs morning's david martin